[Music]
nathan is with us nathan is in omaha
nebraska hi nathan how are you
hey dave pretty good how are you sir
better than i deserve what's up
well that answer uh longtime listener uh
just wanted to get some advice in
regards to a collection company yeah the
most fun people on the earth to deal
with anyways uh got a letter in the mail
uh basically saying that hey notifying
you this is the law office uh we're
gonna sue you if you don't respond
within 20 days over a past due credit
card bill for 625 bucks all right
i was able to get a hold of them today
negotiated a little bit lower discount
rate with monthly payments
here's where it gets a little sticky um
they when i asked them okay how do i
submit the payments you guys want to use
a debit card for autopay you know
whatever they said we don't accept card
payments okay so i figured okay is it
just over the phone or you know do you
have a website no no they don't have
debit card payments at all
period the only way that you can send in
payments is via check in the mail
or on the website or over the phone
providing the writing number and account
number for your checking account
now they did give me an alternative
which was mailing in a money order but
doing the math there it wasn't again not
a very large balance i got it knocked
down from 625 down to 550. why don't you
just pay it discount
well my household income after tax is
1600 my expenses are about 13.
okay have a garage sale this weekend and
pay it
i don't have much to sell off i even got
rid of my car about six months ago
because i got a nice little work from
home job
so you don't own a vehicle
i do not no i decide i just had to
actually sell it um to pay off some
other student loan debt so i had about
four and a half grand still with my
associates that i paid off in full buy
sold my car
in omaha nebraska
yes sir
how do you get around
i work from home i have
i know but you have to leave home
occasionally like go the grocery store
or
yeah so i go to the grocery store just
by picking i literally live about maybe
an eighth of a mile away from my local
grocery store they're open till midnight
just go over there grab what i need
every couple of days and just carry it
home okay what do you do for a living
uh so i actually work for the billing
department for a pretty big hospital in
the state of tennessee um i'm not going
to mention who they are that's okay your
job sucks
yes
it's not fun yeah you make no money
yeah
and that's the problem i mean you have
an income crisis
and it's reflected in the fact that you
can't even cover a 550 bill that's
laying here i'm not picking on you i'm
just telling you look there's two sides
to this equation the out go side the
income side you can't cut expenses far
enough to prosper on sixteen hundred
dollars
yeah
so you've gotta do some things to get
your income up that probably involves
you saving up some money and getting you
a car so that you can get around and go
make some money because you need some
money so uh that i would change your
strategy overall is what i'm saying now
as far as these people go just call them
back and tell them you're not gonna be
able to do it right now
just tell them jump in the creek
you don't have any money there's nothing
they can get you don't have anything
yeah
you know i don't have any money and when
i get some money i'll call you and just
make you a settlement offer and we'll
just work it out i'll send you one check
but and then go about the business
getting your income up and get some
money together and then do it in one
lump sum we do not recommend doing
payments with these goobs because once
they've got your bank information
they're going to clean your butt out and
you're going to be a problem because
they you can tell a credit card
collector's lying if their mouth is
moving
yeah
um so what i do about this whole court
summon things because right now there's
not a court summons they just threatened
you
yeah they hadn't actually sued you
yeah
meaning they lied
okay
they're gonna sue you someday but
they're not gonna sue you before you get
yourself listen a year from now you
can't be sitting where you're sitting
you understand that right oh yeah well i
actually got another job offer it's a
standby offer for for a
claims processor with an insurance
company and that it should be starting
if the position becomes available
somebody fails uh i'll be getting that
job started here in about a month and a
half and that's going to be about a 35
yeah 35 increase for my um with my
current income so
well i think with this amount of money
the 625 which is now 550 you can make
that amount this weekend like you can go
around the neighborhood see if you can
mow lawns offer to paint someone's house
even go to target and get a job this
weekend and work for the next few weeks
like you can tackle this pretty quickly
i even got contemplated going to the
local platform center and donating some
path went to a knockout because
you know hooked me up to the machine
stick a needle on my arm and help save a
lot and get paid for it so i thought
about even doing that
well i i that's okay to do if you want
to do that i i i don't ever tell people
to do stuff i wouldn't do because i
don't do that but um i've done almost
everything else that was legal and moral
to go make some money so christina's
right go make some money and pay this
thing and then here's the deal do not
give them any money unless it's in
writing and never give them your bank
information under any circumstances
because they lie
they will take 625 out of your account
after you have in writing and promise
that it's 550 and you're not going to
sue them for 200 bucks and they know
that yeah exactly that's that was
they're freaking crooks
okay
99 of them they're horrible companies we
work with them all the time and they're
just horrible so no you cannot trust
them and if you're out there and you
work you're a credit card collector and
you don't like what i'm saying then go
get a good job and then you can like me
so because your job sucks so don't do
this so anyway yeah
christine is right go make some money
clean this mess up and do it in one lump
sum and you can send them a money order
you can send them a prepaid debit card
they'll take that believe me if it's a
lump sum one time but do not give them
access to your checking account
ever
in an adversarial situation like this
and do not give them any money until you
have it in writing and you keep a hot
print if it's an email print it off keep
a hard copy with a copy of the receipt
where you sent the money stapled to it
in a file for the rest of your life
because they'll come back around they'll
forget
or joe that used to work here didn't
have authority well in toughies i got it
in writing
and you have you but you can't be like i
i don't remember who i talked to now you
gotta have it in writing
and you gotta have the receipt stapled
to it for the rest of your life
but the good and the bad news is is that
you have a
old credit card debt the good news is
it's only 500.